we have to start with the Bieber this is
clearly the most important news of the
day cops sheriff's showed up to Justin
Bieber's compound i'm calling it a
compound mansion whatever you want to
call it because there was an egg
incident vandalism eggs were thrown
there may have been as much as twenty
thousand dollars worth of damage to
Justin Bieber's neighbor's house
anything over 950 950 dollars would be a
felony the Bieber could be in trouble
lil za I didn't know who he was but
apparently he's a rapper friend of
Bieber he got arrested might be coke
might be ecstasy might be xanax okay so
nobody wants to talk about this up it's
such nonsense but it was literally the
lead story on cnn.com it was trending on
Twitter of course all that stuff in all
the news organizations covering it so I
feel like that's worthy of talking about
how do we decide what should even be in
the discussion and what about the news
organizations like CNN really like front
page like I mean that was the biggest
headline of the day really I mean
they're they're whoring for clicks I
guess I mean that's the only explanation
cuz it's really like it's absurd that
that we are paying this much attention
to like an egg throwing incident you
know it's awful yeah now the irony isn't
lost on me that of course I'm now
talking about it which just means the
Beast did want to say yes look I can see
in the head tilt everywhere going Dave I
know what you're doing here but really
what like so for a regular news
organization I get you can touch on it
but literally when they're covering this
as the lead story not you know we're
having some issues with NSA have you
heard about that and Obamacare and iran
says we surrendered you know so there's
some other [ __ ] going down was also CNN
in the Jeff Zucker world like they've
made a point that they're gonna step
away from kind of classical news in a
lot of ways they're trying to move more
towards entertainment yeah to position
themselves better against MSNBC and Fox
which are kicking their asses over and
over and over again for years so I think
we're still see I mean this is the same
organization that dedicated like what
non-stop covered for like four days to
the poop cruise like very bad but never
forget yeah
hashtag never forget yeah but uh yeah so
I think it's not totally surprising and
but at the same time everybody is
talking about it like it's it's hard
it's a chicken it's a check what is this
situation or the egg situation but
people do are interested and it is kind
of an interesting crazy story yeah it's
completely nuts and I'm not diminishing
the ridiculous of and how many freaking
eggs for twenty thousand dollars worth
of damage I know they obviously
refrigerate the most ridiculous element
of the stories how did you twenty
thousand dollars for the damage with a
carton of eggs people have a thing I
guess they've really fancy windows and
you know stuff like that ridiculous I do
like I think you were right to call be
bursting a compound because he often
think of him in Noriega and they say the
same breath yeah but I can't imagine
what the cops were looking for like what
why do you need 12 like a dozen
detective ever to come talk to him what
are you searching like are you taking
eggs out of the refrigerator mr. Beeba
what do we have it like don't tell me a
friends bought this for it actually is a
great point because we always think that
celebrities get special treatment as if
it's better but in this case if I had
egg my neighbor's house i'm pretty sure
12 cops would have shown up and started
searching my house cuz what is the
evidence there look I mean are they
looking for egg crates they end up
finding cocaine or ecstasy or write that
apparently he's had altercations before
the police and he doesn't usually comply
like he doesn't usually talk to the cops
so i think that like they were just
trying you know he probably was i wasn't
it this was probably an instance of that
you know or he was like not wanting to
talk to them well I think we've given
this story sort of the gravitas that it
deserves but shouldn't we expect this
kind of stuff from rock stars like what
happened to the days when rock stars
were allowed to trash rooms and destroy
you know hotels and burn cows in
airplanes and all kinds of fun stuff
what happened that I don't think they
used to live in these gated communities
in Calabasas though like I think they
they would go in like you know they live
in cities and like Sid and Nancy we're
staying at the Chelsea Hotel you know
like they did trash hotel rooms up but
they also stopped you know now they live
next to bankers and bankers don't give a
[ __ ] like they have real money and like
real like money that will last beyond
time when they're cute okay I think
little za's of the littles oz of the
world are going to have a lot of Justin
Bieber's money by the time it's all said
and done the entourage always seems to
not go broke yeah do you guys think
celebs are having more breakdowns now
it's just that now it's tweeted all the
time like it's lie we're live tweeting
the stuff literally as it's happening
sometimes before it's happening I mean
I'm an incident like this I don't know
if you can if you should necessarily
chalk it up to the fact that he is a
rock star I mean he's still a kid and
you know I grew up in New York City and
I definitely like there were instances
when I would you know bring out some
eggs with friends of mine and throw at
buses which is a fun thing to do and
that that would be a but I think that's
part of girl we do stupid things you
learn from them he the problem with him
is that he doesn't seem to be learning
from them from the stupid things that
he's doing I thought we in the slop
bucket I thought that was going to be
his like fine yeah um so final thought
on this Charlie Sheen I was thinking
about Charlie Sheen with all this
Charlie Sheen's doing blow with hookers
and had you know his whole Tiger was
Tiger juice Tiger Tiger something isn't
it great that we don't remember
hallelujah [ __ ] wonderful I guess
that's the point is the win is that we
forgot what it was yeah but but when you
think about it someone like tight what
do you think he thinks of this like he's
going I'm doing it you know to be like
if I'm gonna do it I'm gonna really do
it and you're egging someone's house
dude justin bieber is sort of like the
real life version of blank check he's
sort of like when a kid gets way too
much money and he's like I'm gonna stay
up all night and drink soda like an egg
houses and and hang out with guys with
coke or ecstasy like he's really mixing
worlds maybe oh yeah it is like the
lamest version of superstardom ever just
you can't imagine Justin Bieber he just
seems like Dennis the Menace which is
not cool like it's he seems like he
literally has his older neighbor being
like you kids get off my lawn like it's
crazy